mayor
is a sergeant detective living in
a community in pennsylvania if you've
got something you want to tell me you
better do it now because i'm going to
start digging through your life
and i'm gonna find out everything and if
you're lying to me it's gonna be very
bad for you
there's an unsolved crime within the
community
so all eyes have been on mayor because
it's fallen to her
and she so far has failed the
communities labeled her a hero but she
never
felt like a hero there's a constant
conflict in mayor of trying to uphold
this image
even though she knows in her heart it's
crumbling i'm just here to help you find
out what happened to those two girls
given your relationships here in town
it couldn't have been easy on you she
deals with a lot she carries enormous
personal grief
we do come to understand why she is the
way she is and why she's had to make
herself
that strong with that kind of coarse
exterior and it's all a coping mechanism
she's just an everyday woman coping with
an enormous amount
can i ask if you're seeing anyone now
just to talk it's been my experience
that it helps parents who've lost you no
no i never um
[Music]
mayer's journey on the show involved
struggles and
the fact that she lost her son to
suicide
and that she has to move on from that in
order to
really grow and be able to be the
detective that the community needs
i loved how vulnerable and strong
at the same time mayor truly is she's
this extraordinary dichotomy of both of
those things
and that sense of her really being
entrenched in a community
i really did find myself becoming
incredibly immersed
in this character largely because of the
fine details
i had to know because any sergeant
detective
investigating a community murder would
have had to know those things too
she's just a persistent detective she
cares about these people
when she doesn't admit it there's a
level of emotion connected to these
girls that makes it personal and she
wants to figure out what happened
we cheer for her along the way and
that's what i hope people
can identify with the most is that she
handles everyone with a great deal of
compassion
and understanding but at the same time
she's kind of firm but fair
she's just a remarkably capable stoic
brave woman who's dealing with all the
elements of family life
and struggle and grief and trying to do
her best
as a mother as a young grandmother and
as a woman in a community that
looked to her so often for answers
you